loi de la violence scolaire cette étude
de l'insee sur la mixité à l'école les
filles marchent mieux que les garçons et
l'écart se creuse dans le secondaire
mais cela ne leur profitent pas sur le
marché du travail on est loin de
l'égalité
florence crif en marine et souvent
volontaires pour aller au tableau
même en chine car la chimie c'est
justement une des matières qu'elle
préfère et pourtant les filles restent
souvent minoritaires dans les sections
scientifiques et techniques les idées
reçues ont encore la vie dure on
s'interdit anticipant de me faire qu on
se dit mais j'ai pas à les faire
mécanique c'est pas pour moi on m'a dit
c'est papa qui fait la mekke bah oui
papa et maman il ya la cuisine donc elle
est aussi bacteria et papa il est
ingénieur donc je vais faire comme papa
j'ai pas faire comme papa chez par un
homme pour je suis pas né vaut lévis les
pièces démontage remontage c'est pas ça
métier de femme il fait si chaud même
niveau clé que les garçons jeu au même
niveau
j'arrive à démonter un vérin j'avais mal
remonté j'arrivais à lire un schéma
électrique
je vois pas où est le problème par
rapport à vous mais c'est la mentalité
vous faut la changer faut arrêter en
allemagne aussi les filles ont parfois
du mal à s'imposer alors dans certains
collèges comme celui ci on a pris les
grands moyens en physique chimie et en
maths
les filles sont séparées des garçons
quand les garçons ne sont pas là on
prendre la parole
les garçons ont tendance à se moquer de
nous quand on fait des erreurs
ici elles prennent donc vous aux
sciences sont complexes et dans le calme
lise les filles lisent beaucoup plus et
prennent volontiers des notes
elle travaille différemment des garçons
qui sont plus remuant
l'expérience a aujourd'hui 7 ans et l'on
constate que les filles hésiterait moins
tenté un bac scientifique en france ce
genre d'expérience n'existe pas on
préfère parier sur la mixité est rappelé
aux filles aucune filière ne leur ai
fermé